I think pain moves people far more
effectively than pleasure does the easy
thing to wait to prove it is point a gun
at someone's head and you have absolute
compliance and they will do what they
need to do automatically just like that
like death is the great motivator and
the gun just reminds you I'm a big fan
of future casting out negative scenarios
so people talk about like positive
visualization I prefer negative
visualization which is what if I keep
doing what I'm currently doing for the
next 10 years will my life look like
then that usually takes my current pain
and then just magnifies it that allows
me to get my action threshold high
enough that it goes over the edge so
that I can take that first move and so
if you know what the inputs outputs are
of what you need to do and you figure
out whatever fuel you've got not the one
you wish you had but the one you've got
and you use that to do the first input
you've crossed the line you're in the
game